let's go next to Joe from New Hampshire
Joe from New Hampshire welcome to the
program
can you hear me yes I can
awesome uh
a two-parter for you sure uh
you know I'm I'm living on a college
campus right now and I would say it goes
without saying that most people around
here are more political than the average
uh population sure um but even then I
meet probably the majority of people I
meet are would consider themselves
apolitical they don't like to touch
politics interesting
um and I'm noticing a lot of people I
meet just in general seem to think that
like being a political is some kind of
virtue
um
so yeah it's similar to enlightened
centrism there are people who believe
that because they're in the middle and
they're like well listen you know one
side wants to kill trans people and the
other wants them to be able to use
whatever bathroom they want I'm in the
middle it's like you're in the middle of
one position That's crazy dude you know
so I think the enlightened centrism is
similar in a way
um but also now let me say one thing
here Joe before you move on go for it I
don't think that political apathy
is a good thing because political apathy
carried to its full conclusion allows
small groups of extremists to basically
decide how our entire political system
works so I think knowing what's going on
and voting very very important at the
risk of turning people off from my own
program I do think there are some people
who are too sucked in to political
issues and events and news that will
never affect them and that they will
never affect and there are people who
have written about this it's not
nihilism but it's sort of understanding
you know okay what am I going to do
about what's going on in Ukraine or the
South China Sea or and I've seen for
some people it becomes unhealthy where
they're so sucked into news and politics
they're just upset they're not doing and
a lot of things they can't do anything
about it other than I might occasionally
donate to a cause or Vote or whatever
the case may be and so I do think it's
important and I do this myself I think
shows like mine if you imagine like a
pyramid instead of a food pyramid it's
like a information pyramid I should be
at the top of the pyramid sort of like
the junk food you're using this to fill
in your understanding of news and events
built on an understanding of history and
other areas built on a foundation of
critical thinking and epistemology and
there are some people who are just
constantly consuming opinion and and I
don't think that that's a good thing to
do
yeah absolutely I I definitely agree
um I think my main concern is that
there's a lot of people who uh for
instance in my state of New Hampshire uh
we elected two uh Democratic senators
but we re-elected the the uh
anti-abortion uh Republican Governor yes
and I was talking with some people after
after I I personally voted and uh they
were talking about who they voted for
and they're like yeah you know I'm not
too political so but you know I still
like abortion so I voted for the two
Democratic senators and the and Chris
sununu because they thought Chris Nunu
was pro-abortion right and they just
like were not critical of who they were
voting for yes no that's a real problem
and I also know people who are like yeah
I'm not really political but I just I'm
kind of more of a republican so I don't
get very involved or pay attention but I
just vote for Republicans but I'm not
really very political and then I talked
to the person and all of their views
actually really align more with the
Democratic party so sometimes that
apathy is actually more destructive than
people who are involved
yeah that's that's kind of what I was
thinking too yeah
well Joe I appreciate you breaking
bringing up the issue it's an important
one yeah thanks for taking my call all
right there's Joe from New Hampshire
great to hear from